hi welcome to the company can I please
have your ID for paperwork do you mean
this I'm Jackie
I'm gonna chain reaching reaching do you
know what you'd like to order I don't
understand this menu I recommend the
chicken slider I'm the virgin
wait what I don't eat meat oh you're a
vegan your friend my name is vici
witching weight reaching No do you have
like an American name
where you from China well I know that
which city chunky it's a close to
Beijing yeah I just got back from a trip
to China
oh yeah which part Singapore Singapore
is not part of China really they're like
Chinese people there a lot of Chinese
around the world how do you say bread in
Mandarin mean bow bow
how do you say peanut butter wash and
jump that's a puppy my Chinese friend
taught me this word do you know what it
means a child Dima it means have a nice
day oh talking about no I'm just kidding
it's a bathroom oh no Alex Chen I went
to school with them it's from China me
[Music]
we Oh Fred
another iPhone 7 that I'm not your
personal shopper that's so cool
it's so cool these speak two languages
like I would love to be able to do that
I really wish that I could translate
from one language to another hey Raj hey
you know what where the cool kids we
yeah right good
love it cool I'll catch you around
reaching
[Music]